this is jeff bezos at 16 years old he
was flipping burgers at mcdonald's in
2021 he became the richest man on the
planet with a net worth of more than 200
billion dollars but it hasn't been all
smooth sailing bezos began his career in
the hedge fund world in the 1990s then
left a cushy job to launch his own
startup that didn't turn a profit for
years in 2018 he weathered a
high-profile divorce scandal and amazon
has faced scrutiny over how it treats
its workers he's since stepped down as
amazon ceo and has been pursuing other
ventures from launching into space
aboard the blue origin rocket to
amazon's domination in various sectors
bezos's conquest to rule the world is
becoming a reality this is how he went
from mcdonald's employee to hedge fund
manager to the richest man on the planet
[Music]
he was born on january 12 1964. his
mother jackie got divorced from her
first husband and married cuban
immigrant miguel bezos who adopted jeff
when bezos was four his mother told his
biological father to stay out of their
lives bezos showed signs of brilliance
from an early age when he was a toddler
he took apart his crib with a
screwdriver because he wanted to sleep
in a real bed
from ages 4 to 16 bezos spent summers on
his grandparents ranch in texas doing
things like repairing windmills and
riding balls
bezos fell in love with reruns of the
original star trek and became a fan of
later versions too in school bezos told
teachers the future of mankind is not on
this planet even as a kid he wanted to
be a space entrepreneur
after spending a miserable summer
working at mcdonald's as a teen he
became obsessed with the idea of
managing employees
bezos together with his girlfriend
started the dream institute a 10-day
summer camp for kids they charged 600 a
kid and managed to sign up six students
bezos eventually went to college at
princeton university and majored in
computer science upon graduation he
turned down job offers from intel and
bell labs to join a new startup
after he quit he got a job at the hedge
fund d.e shore he became a senior vice
president after only four years in 1993
he married mackenzie tuttle a de shore
research associate a year later bezos
read that the web had grown 2 300 in one
year this number astounded him and he
decided he needed to find some way to
take advantage of this rapid growth
[Music]
[Applause]
he made a list of 20 possible products
to sell online and decided books were
the best option
bezos decided to leave d e shaw even
though he had a great job his boss at
the firm david e shaw tried to persuade
bezos to stay but bezos was already
determined to start his own company he
felt he'd rather try and fail at a
startup than never try at all on july
5th 1994 amazon was born jeff bezos and
his wife mackenzie opened an online
bookstore in seattle because of the
city's reputation as a tech hub and
small population they wouldn't have to
charge sales tax to most of their
customer base
bezos financed the company with ten
thousand dollars from his own pocket
he and a small team spent their early
days working in his garage on desks made
out of doors purchased from home depot
in the early days a bell would ring in
the office every time someone made a
purchase and everyone would gather
around to see whether anyone knew the
customer after a few weeks the bell was
ringing so often they had it removed
in the first month of its launch amazon
sold books to customers in all 50 states
and in 45 different countries
on may 15 1997 amazon went public at 18
per share giving it a valuation of 300
million dollars
in june 1998 amazon expanded its
offerings and started selling cds and
dvds the music section launched with 125
000 titles in september 1999 amazon
patented the ability to purchase an item
online with the click of a mouse called
one click the technology gave the
company an early advantage by promoting
customers to buy more and allow the
company to collect their data
amazon would later sue barnes noble for
infringement forcing other websites to
license the technology until the patent
expired in 2017. in november amazon
launched its third-party seller
marketplace that sparked a huge increase
in the volume of transactions on
amazon.com over the first four months a
quarter of a million customers bought
something using the service
in december 10th 1999 amazon took a hit
after the dot-com bubble burst
although it would survive the dot-com
crash amazon wasn't totally immune its
stock peaked at nearly 106 dollars a
share at the end of 1999 before taking a
long slide pummeled by negative analyst
reports
the company would lay off 15 of its
workforce before the stock price
recovered
in the same month time magazine named
bezos person of the year dubbing him the
king of cybercommerce
on june 10th 2003 amazon launched its
web hosting business
the company started to generate extra
income by licensing its platform
to other e-commerce sites like
borders.com and target.com
nowadays amazon web service continues to
dominate cloud hosting and is one of the
company's biggest revenue drivers
in august 2004 amazon entered china
amazon paid 75 million dollars to buy
yoyo the largest online seller of books
and electronics in the growing chinese
market
but the division renamed amazon china
faced stiff competition and was trailing
far behind alibaba in february 2005
amazon prime debuted bezos announced a
79 a year loyalty program that included
free two-day shipping on any order
now with more than 200 million members
worldwide
prime is considered one of amazon's most
valuable assets in november 2007 the
kindle went on sale the electronic
reading device enabled users to
wirelessly download books magazines and
newspaper articles among other content
in january 2008 amazon acquired audible
for 300 million dollars
audible now holds 41 of the audiobook
market which has been growing rapidly
with the rise of smartphones
in march 2012 amazon acquired robotics
company kiva systems for 775 million
dollars the deal allowed amazon to amp
up automation at its fulfillment centers
delivering products faster and with less
need for human staff amazon later
terminated kiva's client relationships
with retailers like office depot and the
gap in order to keep the technology to
themselves
in august 2013 bezos bought the
financially struggling washington post
for 250 million dollars
his plan was to take it private and pump
cash into new staff and better online
products
the newspaper now says it is profitable
in august 2014 amazon acquired the
social video game streaming site twitch
for 970 million dollars the deal not
only complemented the work being done at
amazon's own game production division
but it helped pull the global gaming
community towards its cloud platform
amazon web services
in june 2017 amazon acquired whole foods
after struggling for years in the
intensely competitive grocery delivery
business amazon upped the ante and
purchased whole foods
471 stores for 13.7 billion dollars
it has since started to integrate the
two companies distribution networks and
offer discounts to prime members in
september 2018 amazon reached a 1
trillion market cap in october 2020
amazon sales and profits surged during
the pandemic profits increased 197
percent to 6.3 billion revenue from
amazon web services the company's cloud
computing business and largest profit
driver grew 29
while its advertising business grew 51
in july 2021 jeff bezos hit a new wealth
record and became the richest man on the
planet with a net worth of
211 billion dollars
bezos has often come under fire about
his treatment of employees and other
controversies his former employees
describe bezos as a massive control
freak and amazon as a one-man show
former amazon engineer steve yegi said
bezos made ordinary control freaks look
like stoned hippies
bezos was known to tell his employees
that they should pay him to work at
amazon
in 2002 he demanded all his engineers to
rebuild their systems from the ground up
he also promised to fire every single
person who couldn't pull off this
massive undertaking he also brutalized
employees he had an array of harsh
insults he spewed at his employees with
such anger that blood vessels bulged on
his head amazon veterans have actually
collected a greatest hits list of
bezos's outbursts which range from why
are you wasting my life to labeling his
target incompetent or part of the bt
he's also not interested in charities
out of the four richest americans elon
musk bill gates mark zuckerberg and
himself he's the only one out of the
four who hasn't signed the giving pledge
a campaign to encourage extremely
wealthy people to contribute a majority
of their wealth to philanthropic causes
but in all fairness bezos has made some
charitable donations over the years in
2020 cbs news reported he launched the
bezos earth fund to help fight climate
change with a 10 billion dollar gift in
2018 he started the day one fund which
aims to devote two billion dollars to
address homelessness and education
issues
but it's still a minuscule amount
compared to the 41.3 billion bill gates
gave in charitable donations between
2000 and 2016. he's also a self-admitted
tax dodger bezos famously decided to
found amazon in washington state instead
of the hot tech hub of california and
was perfectly happy to admit that he did
it to dodge california's sales taxes
amazon's attitude toward taxes hasn't
exactly changed through the years as a
massive economic player it's able to
parlay governments and states for
billions and billions of tax deductions
in 2017 the company made 5.6 billion in
pure profit and in 2018 cnbc reported a
profit of 11 billion dollars yet amazon
paid no federal income taxes whatsoever
this gives them a price advantage over
traditional book retailers and help them
to establish a strong foothold in
e-commerce he's also known to pick on
smaller players in different markets
bezos ordered his employees to approach
small publishers the way a cheetah would
pursue a sickly gazelle amazon
executives took such sadistic pleasure
in abusing publishers that they named
its publisher abusing business program
the gazelle project he also made
employees work against each other
employees were actively encouraged to
bash each other's ideas during meetings
and the company's internal phone
directory even features instructions on
how to give secret feedback about their
co-workers to their bosses the system
was called the anytime feedback tool
using it to snitch on a fellow worker
was so simple that it even provided
sample text
the system made the work environment
extremely stressful for employees
amazon warehouses are often described as
prisons life in an amazon warehouse is
so hectic that workers don't have enough
time to eat or drink properly some of
the employees even peed in bottles and
left them on the shelves because the
performance targets were so high that
they didn't have time to take a bathroom
break
many employees complained that the
targets are too high surveillance is
constant the pay is inadequate and
workplace injuries are depressingly
common
he also came under fire for a texting
scandal on january 9 2019 jeff bezos
announced on twitter that he and his
wife of 25 years mackenzie bezos were
divorcing he had developed a
relationship with former tv anchor
lauren sanchez some even released
private photos and messages in which
bezos was said to flaunt his strangely
robotic sexting skills he supposedly
wrote to sanchez i love you alive girl
and i will show you with my body and my
lips and my eyes very soon in july 2019
a settlement was reached with mackenzie
receiving 38 billion dollars over the
next two years she donated billions to
charities across a variety of sectors
in 2021 mackenzie married science
teacher dan jewett in a statement jeff
bezos wished the newlyweds well saying
dan is such a great guy
on july 5th 2021 jeff bezos stepped down
as ceo of amazon to focus on his other
ventures
now more than 20 years after going
public amazon has a market cap of over
1.4 trillion dollars at the time of
making this video
bezos and sanchez have had a whirlwind
two years attending wimbledon together
yachting with other moguls and
celebrities and vacationing in san
tropez they even got to meet leonardo
dicaprio
he's still involved in important
initiatives at amazon but he plans to
spend more time on philanthropy
including the bezos earth fund and his
day one fund as well as his two other
major endeavors the washington post
which he purchased in 2013 and his
rocket company blue origin his first
space flight with blue origin was a
success he launched into sub-orbital
space with three other people on the
first crewed mission of the company's
new shepard vehicle a landmark moment
for the man and the space tourism
industry in recent years bezos and elon
musk have seen their respective net
worth spike the two moguls have
flip-flopped for the spot of the world's
richest person though it appears elon
musk is staying on top with a fortune of
over 200 billion dollars there's no
doubt that jeff bezos is incredibly
successful he went from flipping burgers
at mcdonald's to becoming the richest
man on the planet
what can we learn from bezos's rise to
the top
well the reason why amazon is so
successful is that bezos has an
obsession with customer experience
amazon selection ease of use low prices
and fast delivery times are unparalleled
and it's the reason why amazon dominates
the retail space and while most
businesses focus on a particular market
amazon is involved in a wide variety of
industries such as logistics streaming
cloud storage payments and the list goes
on they've built an entire ecosystem
that has made amazon insanely profitable
but by doing so they've compromised in
their treatment of employees and working
conditions by making customers their
number one priority amazon workers have
suffered due to the high expectations
and workload
some argue that bezos should be more
charitable while others argue that it's
his money and he can do whatever he
wants with it with regards to his tax
evasion critics often point out it's
unfair that he pays such little tax
while earning hundreds of millions per
day but some argue that big companies do
it all the time and if they do it
legally then they shouldn't owe the
government a penny is he a great
businessman who values his customers or
is he a real life lex luthor
the comment section in this one will be
very interesting
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one